Avengers end game may very well be the
last time we see the nose as a villain
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
though the comics have plenty of bad
guys to choose from filling Thanos his
shoes won't be easy it's got to be
someone truly powerful and truly scary
here's a look at some of the villains
who could be the next MCU big bad after
Thanos in Marvel Law the Celestials are
a race of cosmic beings who created
intelligent life-forms across the galaxy
including humanity as a grand experiment
and when that experiment fails to meet
their standards the Celestials end there
they've already shown up in guardians of
the galaxy with one of their heads
serving as the outpost called nowhere
and the rumoured to possibly be in the
upcoming Eternals movie meaning the
heroes of the MCU could literally meet
their makers sooner rather than later of
the villains we've actually seen in the
MCU are possibly the most staggeringly
powerful sat god-like Dormammu of 2016's
Doctor Strange even Stephen strange
himself realized he had no prayer of
defeating Dormammu so he resorted to
some clever trickery to get the entity
to promise not to mess with earth again
but oaths are made to be broken and if
Dormammu returns it might take the
combined might of all the MTU heroes to
stop him one of the better kept secrets
of infinity war was a surprise
reappearance of Captain America's old
enemy
the Red Skull audiences hadn't seen him
on the big screen since 2011 Captain
America the First Avenger and the
Crimson faced Hydra found his fate had
been something of a mystery with Thanos
gone though Red Skull may finally be
free to return to Earth and who knows
how his experience in space has changed
him the dude was dangerous enough even
before being cursed by an infinity stone
now he might even be a match for the
Avengers ever since fans learn that the
shape-shifting alien scrolls were going
to appear in Captain Marvel there's been
speculation about a big screen version
of Secret Invasion the 2008 Marvel
comics event that revealed the
shape-shifting aliens have been
infiltrating the earth for years or
maybe the groundbreaking 1971 epic
kree-skrull Wharf which was at the heart
of Captain Marvel sure the scrolls in
that film turned out to be okay but
there could be plenty more that may not
be quite so nice meaning either of these
epic storylines could still be in store
for MCU fans when a Marvel comics reader
thinks
a cosmic world threatening villain
Galactus is probably the first one to
come to mind an immortal entity he was
lived since before the Big Bang Galactus
must feed his insatiable hunger by
devouring entire planets whole he sort
of made an appearance in 2007 s
Fantastic Four Rises the Silver Surfer
but not really as he was just a goofy
cloud now that Disney has reacquired the
rights to collectors from 20th Century
Fox a glimpse of his classic outfit and
hearing some booming voice say a hunger
would be all you need to get fans ready
for phase 4 how awesome would it be to
see the Avengers fight the Justice
League well it's not as crazy as you
think because Marvel actually has their
own version of the Justice League called
the squadron supreme this alternate
universe group of Heroes features
characters that are all analogs of DC
icons like Superman Wonder Woman Green
Lantern flash and Aquaman sure it would
be a cheeky surprised if Marvel decided
to risk a lawsuit from Warner Brothers
by promoting the squadron to star
players but comic book fans will be over
the moon
the payoff might just be worth the risk
it isn't clear whether or not Mark
Ruffalo will be continuing to appear as
the Hulk after avengers endgame but if
he does there's an intriguing option on
the table
maestro it's been rumored for a while
that Bruce Banner and Hulk may reconcile
that differences from Avengers infinity
war by combining into Professor Hulk a
version of the character who has the
Hulk's brute strength but banners
brilliant mind now imagine what might
happen if someone like that turned evil
that's the idea behind maestro who in
the comics is a future version of Hulk
who has taken over the world and
murdered all the other heroes in the
process now there's a threat that's
truly chilling when it comes to Avengers
villains though there's one that stands
out above all the rest above low key
above Ultron and even of a fan OHS Kang
the Conqueror in the comics no villain
has more consistently given the Avengers
more trouble than Kang a warlord from
the distant future who uses time travel
to invade other eras with his Senate
logically superior armies Kang gets
another character whose rights had been
tied up a 20th Century Fox but now that
Avengers endgame is rumored to involve
time travel it seems like the time might
finally be right for Kang to make his
long-awaited appearance
arguably Marvel's most important villain
in the comics dr. doom has appeared in
two different Fox iterations of the
Fantastic Four movie franchise and both
versions have been for lack of a better
term total poop but like Galactus Marvel
Studios now has the movie rights to the
character so they can do the doom right
Doctor Doom is the presence and the
power to give anyone a run for their
money
not only is he basically an evil Tony
Stark with genius-level intellect and a
suit of super armor to match he's also a
sorcerer who can hang with dr. strange
and you know what can happen when more
than one powerful doctor gets in the
same room together well I have to say
anything I'm a doctor too and those
aren't the only heroes for whom Doctor
Doom as an evil reflection think seeing
a big screen version of Wakanda ruled by
the heroic Black Panther was amazing
imagine how awesome it be to see an MCU
version of Doctor Doom ruling Latveria
with a literal iron fist
in the comics he's beaten the Avengers
and taken over the world single-handedly
so we can't wait to see him in the MCU
sooner or later check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the Avengers are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]